[Music]
last summer North Korea tested its first
intercontinental ballistic missile the
technology Donald Trump said or wouldn't
happen but it did again
and again
and you can go check out young along
with the country's most powerful nuclear
test I think the North Koreans have an
ICBM that can deliver a large nuclear
weapon to United States they will be met
with fire and fury in response they're
worthless writers things will happen to
them like they never thought possible
personal insults little Rocket Man
Rocket Man is on a suicide mission for
himself he is a sick puppy this is
writing North Korean propaganda for
those boots the situation was on the
brink of conflict
if war comes make no mistake the North
Korean regime will be utterly destroyed
this president and his administration
are considering limited military options
more seriously than any of his
predecessors but then came the Winter
Olympics in South Korea the first talks
in two years
the first unified Olympic team and an
unexpected truce
[Music]
the new year in North Korea started with
fireworks and kim jong un's annual
speech headbands work near home since
it's only most of the focus was on his
claim to have a nuclear button on his
desk and the entire US mainland no in
range but then he offered to talk to the
Soviet Union and sent a delegation to
their Olympic Games
[Music]
[Applause]
there have been fierce North Korea would
disrupt these events now there were
soaring statements of optimism in the
Olympic spirit the Olympic Winter Games
Pyongyang 2018 are hopefully opening the
door to a brighter future
on the Korean Peninsula for the first
time Olympians from the North and South
will compete as one who women's ice
hockey
inside the new Olympic Stadium both
politics and sport will be on show so
this is where the two careers will march
together under the unified flag in what
the South Korean president is already
calling the peace Olympics the question
is whether this is really the start of
something significant a lasting peaceful
resolution were just a temporary pause
in hostilities our security is yesterday
okay we can leave with a nuclear-armed
North Korea
professor moon Chung in is a special
adviser to South Korea's president he
wants talks with realistic demands if we
ask North Korea to disarm its nuclear
arsenal from the beginning
it would be impossible for North Korea
to come to the dialogue and negotiation
under the assumption right therefore we
got to have a some kind of low
expectation maybe freezing north korean
nuclear and missile activation would be
the most important step but others say
the Kim family rulers have broken every
agreement they entered into and believe
Kim Jong unlike his father is playing
for time and respite from sanctions
solemn Kadyrov are a damn bangerra pure
door Oh taro hair indonesian competence
da da da da Arizona where gene and she's
not one critic on interior Kojima
Rotondo co-editor tone cemetery wall
North Korea better get their act
together where they're gonna be in
trouble like few nations ever have been
in trouble in this world President Trump
is said to be following a strategy of
maximum pressure
do not try us but so far repeated
warnings today for the 10th time this
counsel stands united against the North
Korean regime and successive frames of
UN sanctions have failed to halt the
regime's weapons program his officials
talk about learning the lesson of Iraq
and Lybia surrender your nuclear arsenal
and you surrender your grip on power I
don't think that there is a level of
pain we could inflict on North Korea
that would get Kim to give up his
weapons I mean from his perspective nuke
if he gives up those nuclear weapons his
his 10 years older
[Music]
just over a couple of hours drive from
the Olympic Village this is what's known
as the truce village where the ceasefire
was signed at the end of the Korean War
those of you smilin now stands in
communist North Korea all those on the
other side is still low city state
within the Republic with no peace
agreement in place both sides remain on
permanent guard on the front lines of a
conflict never ended just frozen in time
we've been given strict rules about what
we're able to do here we've all been
given these press armbands to wear
because over there is North Korea and
everyone here is very aware that
everything they do is being monitored by
the other side and this is a real
reminder for all of the optimism around
these Olympic Games that the reality on
the ground here hasn't changed this
peninsula is still divided and these
countries are technically still at war
these are Marines and us 7th division
troops dancing into Seoul under enemy
fire the Korean War started in 1950 in
the three years of fighting that
followed more than two and a half
million people died it is reported that
the Reds have 30,000 men defending
jian-yang who was in the north are not
told that their leader Kim jong-un's
grandfather started this war they're
told that they were attacked by the
United States so now they need nuclear
weapons to protect themselves
since coming to power in 2011 the
current leader has been pictured taking
personal charge of that
the pace of testing and the range of
those missiles has increased
I think the North Koreans have an ICBM
that can deliver a large nuclear weapon
to the United States I think the place
where it gets complicated is how
reliable is it from a kind of 10,000
foot policy of you I think we should get
used to the idea that they can do this
that prospect may not be quite as
unsettling as it sounds
Kim jong-un's nuclear ambitions are well
documented what is less often discussed
as the other half of his strategy what
he refers to as byeongjin or parallel
advanced the first half is the nuclear
deterrent but the second half is
economic development and despite the
resources he's put into the missile
program a nuclear program despite the
sanctions which have been steadily
increasing everything we see suggested a
North Korean economy has been growing
under his leadership so you know that's
the peace of Kim jong-un that gives us
some hope I mean that's where he looks
like actually a typical East Asian
dictator all great teachers great
leaders come on
[Music]
he's the red Sun you know
this is not the first time the United
States has encountered an adversary
determined to develop nuclear weapons in
the 1960s these were the celebrations of
China's new status as a nuclear power
under Chairman remote china underwent
serious economic sanctions and embargoes
from both the Soviet bloc when the
Sulochana relationship went bad and from
the American block during the Cold War
you know given the similarity of Chinese
political ideology that Isco and the
political ideology in North Korea today
I think many Chinese officials believe
they better understand the thinking and
logic of the North Korean leadership it
was a question I had for four Chinese
experts I said you know what why don't
the North Koreans just be like you guys
you know and why don't they you know
focus on their economy and they can
still be a communist party but like
China and its Chinese the one answer I
got was they are like us they're doing
what we did this is precisely our path
but for Donald Trump that path would
mean doing the one thing successive u.s.
presidents have sworn never to do
accepting a nuclear-armed North Korea
the politics of that are hard it's much
easier to make bombastic friends if we
take that option it will be devastating
I can tell you that devastating for
North Korea that's called the military
option but the problem with every
military option is the same one all of
his predecessors faced the danger into
the South Korean capital Seoul there's
been some talk lately about the merits
of a limited military strike on North
Korea what's been called the bloody nose
strategy in the US the logic is that Kim
jong-un would understand that this
wasn't the start of an all-out attack
and he's not suicidal so he would sit
back take his medicine and the message
that the United States is serious
but if they're wrong about that this
city and the millions of people who live
here
would be within artillery range of the
North Korean response it's really I
think one of the craziest ideas I've
ever heard you know look ultimate losers
in any kind of military crash the South
Korea I think a bloody no strategies the
worst of all worlds
on one hand to use force in order to
send some sort of symbolic message
you're risking retaliation and
potentially nuclear retaliation for that
the Nixon administration actually had
this exact same problem with North Korea
in 1969 North Koreans shot down a u.s.
reconnaissance airplane and there was a
huge debate about how to strike North
Korea in order to show them that we were
very displeased and at no point could
they come up with a strike that they
were sure the North Koreans wouldn't
confuse for the beginning of an eight
there are no good options but what is
certain that even as North Korea's
athletes arrive for these games back
home the regime's capability is
advancing and this truce won't last
forever
[Music]
when the Olympic flame goes out missile
tests and the military drills will
resume with both sites moving closer to
the break